[Musique]
je me souviens clairement de la première fois que j'ai vu
star wars bonjour là
c'est un monde surréaliste d'y
revenir après toutes ces années
était très significatif pour moi
mon premier jour sur le plateau j'ai crié obi-wan
j'ai vu un  main levée
je me sens extrêmement chanceux de pouvoir le faire
mais aussi une grande responsabilité d'essayer
de le faire correctement
obi-wan kenobi est un personnage emblématique
je ne pense pas que j'imaginerais l'ampleur de
la série
ça m'a époustouflé
tant de gens ont une relation si émotionnelle
avec la galaxie star wars
c'est dans la vie de tout le monde
[Musique]
vous